では よろしくお願いします
と 初めて参加の方々いらっしゃいますか
最初にこのダンマパダというお釈迦様の言葉を集めたところがございますで
そこから少々仏教は何なのかという説法をいたします
と 何番でしたかとはわからない
うん 三十五 デュンニンガハッサラフノヤッタカーマニパーティノチッタッサダマトサドゥチッタンダンタンすかわん
デュンニンガハッサラフノヤッタカーマニパーティノチッタッサダマトサドゥチッタンダンタンすかわん
という偈です で 今日も心について語られているところ
難しくはないんです といっても
説明するってされたところで難しくなるかもしれません
デュンニッガハッサという言葉がありますね
ニッガハっていうのは
この まあもう掴まるっていうことなんです
ドゥ入ったら難しいということで
だから掴みがい 掴みがいっていうことです
次の言葉はラフノ ラフノっていうのは
まあまあ とりあえずもうあまりにも早いという風に理解しても構いませんね
掴めない もうあちこち逃げ回る
早い で ですから落ち着かないという意味でもいいんです
まあこちらは軽々とざわめきっていう意味でしょうかね
次の言葉はヤッチャームニパーティノ
ヤッチャっていうのはこの関係代名詞でこの場所を表すところですね
どこかっていう意味で
カーマっていうのは好きなところ
ニパーティノっていうのは
まあ降りる 落ちるという
着くということで だから好きな好きなところに着いてしまうんですよ
べったりと それは今まで説明したのはこの心の特色ですね
心はそんなものです 一番目はつかみがい
なかなか掴めないんです
それからまあいい加減でね
ざわめくっていう まあそういえば走り回るって
まあ落ち着きがなく 軽々しいっていう意味でもありますよ
[笑い]番目の特色は
好きなところにベッタリと着いている
だから 好きな好きなものから好きなものから好きなものへともう走り回って逃げ回っていて
落ち着きのない心ですよ
従ってつかみ難い 自分の心って何なのかっていうことは分かりにくいということになっています
それで二行目に入ります
三行か そういうチッタッサ
心のダマと制御管理 こんなような心の制御管理はサードゥ
素晴らしいことですと
だから心を調教しなさいよと
それすごくいいことだよと
それで理由を言うんですね
最後に なぜならばという理由
チッタンダンタンスカワハン
チッタン心 ダンタン 制御した心
調教した心が スカワハン幸福をもたらす
ワハンというのは降ってくるという
流れてくるということなんですね
だから心を調教したならば
その心から幸福 幸せがもう流れ出るんです
それが理由なんです これでお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
この人間に語れないほど完璧に語るんです
論理的にも だからまず心はこういうものであるという状況を説明する
それから我々は何をするべきかということを説明する
そこでその理由と結果を説明する
完璧です 四行目で こういう風にまとめるということはなかなか難しいんです
また 詩ですからね そう好き勝手に単語を使うこともできない
好き勝手に伸ばしたり
縮めたりすることもできない
その詩にはそれなりの決まりというものは一般的にありますからね
詩っていうのは一応歌うものだから
まあもう文章みたいな
そういう書くとね 歌えたところじゃないんだからね
節は崩れますから だからこのやっぱり文字数やらね
行数やらね 長短のね 長音
短音 そういうのはいろいろ厳しい決まりがあるんです
その決まりの中で語ってるんです
まあ今日の芸はそれぐらいですね
心は捉えにくいという
この捉えにくいっていうことは
大体みんな我々もね 心って何やとわからないでしょ
一応 それが面白いんですよ
この体から心が出て行っちゃうと
体は単なる物体になるんです
腐りかける かけていく液体になるんです
何もなくなっちゃう だから物質的なものに心という機能が入った時点で
私たちは生命と言うんです
生きていると言うんです
ものすごい機能なんですよ
生命と生きているというものは
外の世界を認識する 自分以外のものを認識する
壊れたら自分で自己処理する
例えば 我々の体が外の世界を認識しているでしょうね
体っていうのはずっと壊れっぱなしなんです
壊れるわ 壊れるわ だからずっと絶えず壊れているんですけど
私たちは全部これ処理しているんです
自分で 例えばご飯食べたり呼吸したりすることも体の処理なんです
これ毎日やらなかったら
もう体壊れてしまいます
心は逃げちゃうんですもん
だから絶えず呼吸するということは
絶えず心が壊れているんだということなんです
だから そういうことが心でやっているんです
心が入っているんだから
それできているんですよ
例えば薬でも何でもいいんだから
心の機能をものすごく低下させちゃうと呼吸できないんです
それで死んでしまうんです
体が自分の自力で呼吸しないとね
今現代だったらね 何か機械に入れて
まあ復活するまでは呼吸させますけどね
ということは もう体っていうのは
肉体っていうのはもう簡単に壊れる
で そういう簡単に壊れることが自己処理するんですよ
これがすごい面白いことなんですよ
例えば何か機械やらね
壊れたっても全然自分では処理しないんです
壊れたということもないんですよ
我々は勝手に壊れてるんだって言うんです
例えば車が壊れたんだと
車にしてみれば 別に壊れて何でもないんです
まあ大体壊れない まあ壊れたり
またもう老化したり いろいろ崩れていくでしょ
物質も でもあまり気にしないね
自然の流れで で 壊れていくだけ
だから自分で処理するということは
生命だけやっているんです
だから生き続けたいっていうのは
この鉄でも物質でも何でもないんです
建物は全然生き続けたいということを思ってないんです
そう作った我々は 建物が長い年月維持してほしいと思うのは我々なんです
だからこの肉体も別に壊れたくないとか
そんなのは全然考えてないんです
しかし その心が死にたくないと思っているんですね
壊れたくないと だから自己処理して
ずっともう壊れるところは直していくんですよ
そういう風に壊れるところは直すんですが
このスピードの差が生まれるんですよ
壊れることが早くなっちゃって
処理するスピードが遅くなるんです
それが何と言いますかね
老化っていうのはそういうことなんです
そこで死ぬんですよ 必ず
しかし 死にたくはないんです
だから心にはこのもう想像を絶する力があるんです
世界変えているのは心なんです
もう何でもいじっても何とかするんです
だから まあ壊すことも
まあ作ることも なかなかな心にはできますよ
物質には全然そういう力がないんです
ただそのままいるだけです
鉄には空を飛べる能力はないんです
アルミニウム 鉄にも そのまま土の中にいるだけで
土と一緒に そこは取り出していろいろ組み立てて空を飛ばすのは人間の心なんですよ
空を飛んでいる飛行機は自分が空を飛んでいるんだとか全然ないんです
そんな考え方が 空を飛んでいても空港に止まっていても
その物質は物質の法則で老化していくんです
全然変わらないんです
しかし 人間の心はそうはさせないんです
いろんなことをするんです
心はだらしないということが世界を見てもわかるんですよ
人間が何を作ったっても
ろくなものを作ってないんですよ
欠陥だらけなんです そんなに役に立ちません
だから一つ何か役に立つというものを作ると
それから受ける損というのはもっとひどいんです
だから なかなか心っていうのはこの一方的で
全面的に物事は考えようとしないので
例えば食いたいと思ったらいきなり山も全部削っちゃって
もう畑作るんであって
それから自分が生きている土台はどうなるのかって
それはどうでもいいんです
ただ ジャガイモ手に入ればいいということになる
ジャガイモに虫がついちゃうと
いきなり毒を撒いちゃうんです
虫を殺したぞと 自分が食べるジャガイモはどうなるかって
それはもう後で考えるんで
病気になってから がんになって死にかけたところで考えるんです
だから心に物事っていうのはすごい一方的にしか見えないんです
その鼻の先の利益しか見えないんです
だからこの心が考えて物事をやっているんだからといって
それをすごいと まあそうは言えませんよ
こんなに世界改良したんだから
人間の心っていうのは大したもんだなとかね
それそうやって感動するのはバカなんですよ
何やったのかと 別に何もしなかったことと
何もしなかったならば
我々は自然のにさらされて結構苦労しているんですよ
自然の流れの中で 生きるのは大変ですよ
だから物を作ったんだからといって生きることが楽になったかというと
全然楽になってないんです
まるっきり同じ割り当てで我々は苦しんでいるんです
だから洞窟の中に生活したっても
すごいインテリビルの中で生活したっても
楽とは言えないんですよ
一方的 事に考えるんだから
これが幸せだと言うかもしれませんだけど
例えば洞窟に住んでいる人が世の中を見て私は幸せだと言うかもしれません
あれ一方的な見方なんです
インテリビルに住んでいる人
私こそ幸せだと言うかもしれませんが
それも一方的な見方なんです
どうってことないんです
そんな大胆なことを心に考えるはずもないんです
だから面白いことは 物質と命と比べてみると
命っていうのは心なんです
物質と言えば 土 物質でしょうし
ペットボトルも物質でしょうし
自分たちが着ている服も物質でしょうし
それと命は随分違うんです
それが心なんです だから心がわからないというのはどういうことかと
と聞きたいですが 心がわからないんですよ
人間堂々と言うんだから
心って一体何でしょうかねと心で考えて聞くんですよ
私はそれはノーノー働けたと思いますよと言って心で考えて言うんです
心って何よとわからないんだったらね
心って心って何よと考えることもできるんでしょうし
心って何ですかと我々に聞くこともできるんでしょうし
明確にもう心が機能しているし
心で生きているし 心に支配されているし
心に生かされているし
なのにこれがわからない
ということは 心ってどういうことかと
このラフのいい加減ですよ
人にあなたはどんな性格でしょうかと
あなたはどんな人でしょうか？と聞いたっても
本人はわからないでしょうね
他人は言うかもしれませんだけど
肝心の自分がわからないでしょ
自分が何者かっていうことは
他人は言いますよ あの人はこういう人だ
この人はこのような人だと
とかね 本人がわからない
私はどういう人でしょうかと
本当にわからないんです
しかし 言いますよ 私はこういう人です
私はこういう人ですとかね
あれはどれぐらい嘘をついているのかと
その自分のことを表現する場合は
いつでも全て隠して綺麗なイメージを出そうとしているんです
自分をありのままに出そうとはしないんです
だから自分で見ようとしないんです
本物の自分を 自分がすごくよくできていて
悪いことをしない 信頼できる
よく頑張る しっかりしている人間だと
みんなそういうことは平気で言い触らしています
そんなに信頼できる人間だったら
世の中困ること何もないでしょうに
それでこのだから掴みにくい
自分でも見ようとしないんだから
見たらまずいんだから
イメージ崩れますから
だから見ないんですよ
そういうことで その肝心の個人に自分自身の心をとらわら
とり なんていうか掴み難くなっているんです
3番目に 2番目に特殊で
ラフノっていうのはすごい軽いというかね
しっかりしないっていうのもあるし
だからもうすぐ逃げ回る
駆け回る ざわめく いい加減というね
よくわかりやすく言えば随分いい加減
信頼はできない 約束はできない
だからほんのちょっとでもいいんだから
この我々 この世間に向けて自分がこういうものだと言っている
このもうとてつもない嘘をちょっと置いておいて
このイメージをね ちょっと置いておいて
で考えてみると 自分が本当に信頼できるのかと
すぐ心が変わるんですよ
瞬時に変わる これはやりませんと思ったっても
そんな約束はできないんです
やる可能性はあります
これはやりますと約束したってもやらない可能性はいくらでもあります
私は怒りませんと言っても
そんなに約束できません
私は欲張りませんよと
できますかね？私は他人には親切だよと
そんなのは自分がこういうものか言うのは全部嘘でしょうに
他人に親切でしょうと言ったって
本当に親切ですかね すぐ心が変わって
もう何やるか分からないんです
だからいい加減という
ラフノーっていうのは
それは自分にも管理できない
3番目の特色はやった
カーマ・ニパーティノ
そこははっきりしています
心が好きなところにすぐべったしとついてしまうんです
磁石は鉄だったらすぐついてしまうでしょうし
プラスチックあったらもうあることさえも知らない
そういう感じで 我々の心も
心が好きなもの 人が好きなものじゃないんです
自分の心が好きな好きな好きなものにべったしべったし着いちゃうんです
だからこそ心っていうのは
人っていうのは信頼できないんです
その人は何が好きか分からないでしょうに
本人も分からないんだ
他人分かるはずないでしょうに
それでいくら頑張るぞと言っても
何か好きなものなんかそこら辺に着いてくると
すぐそちらに行っちゃうんです
そこまでは心の特色で
それに自動的に結論が出ているんですよ
そういういい加減 わがまま
中途半端な 信頼できない
見ようともしていない心をしっかり見て調教した方が
それほどありがたいことないでしょうという答えがもう自動的に出ているはずなんです
なぜかで心を全部支配しているんだから
我々は安全ですかね 約束できない
信頼できない だらしない
中途半端 いい加減で 全くの信頼できないものに支配されて
それで幸福になるということはあり得るんでしょうかね
だからこれ オオカミにニワトリの留守番なんでした
何です 留守番と言わないね
苦手 見張りを頼んだら安全ですかね
それでこの自分がこの嘘のイメージを作ってね
人間がね 言い張ってるんだから
決して自分の心を見たくないんです
見ないものは調教できん
見ようとも触ろうともしないんだったら
もうほっぽり出してるでしょうに
ですから この心を調教した方がよろしいんだと
どうせ支配者だから その支配者をしっかりしておけば
清らかなものにしておけば
間違い犯さないものにしておけば
偏見で一方的な物事を見るんじゃなくて
全面的に物事を判断する
理解するものにしておけば
もう幸せになるのは決まってるでしょう
そういうことで 人間にある唯一の仕事は
自分の心を訓練することなんです
他本職はないんです 生きているものの本職は自分の心を育てることなんです
他やることっていうのは何一つもないんですよ
別に みんな何やってるんでしょうかとわからないんですけど
大体我々やってること考えてみてください
本当に何大事なことなんかやってるんですかと
他やること何一つもない
で これから注釈書の説明いろいろありますが
うん 一般的に訳はこの英訳は
このドゥンニッガッといういうのは掴みにくい
捉えにくいということになってますから
当然日本訳っていうのは英訳見て書いてるんですから
誰一人も日本語パーリ語から直訳した人はいませんだからね
日本語って日本で だから一箇所間違うと誰でも間違うんで同じところ
ニッガーっていうのは叱るという意味は普通なんです
怒鳴る叱る ですから ドゥンニッガになってくると叱りにくいと言われる
育ちにくいということなんです
叱るということはまあしつけですからね
怒るということじゃないんです
しつけ 悪いこと 悪い状況をものすごく叱ってしっかりさせるというしつけなんです
それが難しいんだというのは注釈書の意味なんです
ラフというラフノという言葉の注釈書の説明はちょっとわからないと思います
あれすごい専門的な言葉です
こちらで言ってるのは
この一番簡単に生まれて消えていくのは心なんです
何か物質的なものを作ろうと思っちゃうと結構難しいんです
心っていうのは簡単に生まれて簡単に消える
例えば怒るっていうか
すごい簡単でしょうに
何か見たら綺麗やと思うのは簡単でしょうに
あ 汚いと思うのは簡単でしょうに
綺麗と見る心と汚いと見る心はまるっきり別質で別々なんです
同じ心じゃないんです
だから簡単に心が生まれて消えていくんです
とってもとても簡単 だからそれは一番簡単な起こるいいことなんです
世界で 机でも １０センチぐらい別なところに行こうと思うと結構大変です
心変えようとしてれば随分簡単です
変える 簡単に勝手に それがラフンということで
ザワメフっていう意味っていうのはそんなには入ってないと思います
そこでもうちょっとこのもっとヤッタカーニパタナ 3番目は注釈書でもっとわかりやすく説明します
欲しくなったらもう何も他のことを考えないんだと心は
何かやろうと思っちゃうと
もうあまり結果とかね
周りとか考えないんです
やってしまうんです で
強盗でもしたいなと思ったら
それ強盗することしか考えないんです
それからどうなるかと
それやっていいのかって
それはどうでもいいんです
誰か人のことを気に入ったら
もうその人結婚しているかいないか
年上か下か それはどうでもいいんです
それは見えなくなるんです
それを言っちゃうと怒るんですよ
あんた あの人随分年上でしょうと
もっと考え直したらどうでしょうかと言っても聞いてくれないんです
大体その時だけ心は寂しそうはないんですね
悪いことする時だけ それ
限りはもう完全に差別主義で生きてるんです
まあ一応この今日のお釈迦様の言葉の意味は
まあそれぐらいで十分だと思います
育ちにくい心はすごい育ちにくい
躾しにくいもので まあいい加減で簡単に変わってしまう動くもので
それから好きなものだったら目がないという状態で
他何も見えなくなるもので
しかし その心を調教した方がいいと
でないと幸福にはなりっこはないんです
で ちょっと面白い物語がありまして
まあ長いんだからね  60人のお坊さんたちが
お釈迦様から瞑想指導を受けるんです
阿羅漢になるまで一回で教えてもらうんで
こういうふうに瞑想するんだよと
大体瞑想指導っていうのはほとんど一回きりで
それで真面目に修行して悟って帰るんですけど
それでコーサラ国のかなり田舎に
コーサラ国っていうのは結構近いですからね
だから街から離れて結構田舎の方に行ったんです
ある村がありまして その村に行って
まあ人々から 町から みんなから離れて
では瞑想するんだぞということで出て行ったんです
指導下でかなり遠く行ってしまうんです
その村であるお母さんがいて
そのお母さんがお坊さんたちがまあ 60人も来たのを見て
まあすぐ早くも食事を用意してお布施するんです
で このお母さんが お坊さんたちは随分遠くから来たでしょうしね
だからまあ 60人にもちゃんとご飯を作って差し上げて
でお坊様方はどこに行くんでしょうかと聞いたんです
そこで我々はこのちょっと落ち着く場所を探しているんだよと
いわゆる静かな 落ち着いていられる場所を探しているんだということで
まあ大体このお釈迦様に会うことできるのもこの雨後の前ですから
まあ夏 日本でいえばちょっと夏前なんですね
大体 6月  7月 雨後というね
まあ 3ヶ月間入りますから
で 残りの日にちでは大体お釈迦様は旅に出ますし会ったりすることもできる
で でお坊さんたちがそれで指導を受けて出て行ったんですから
大体まあ雨季に入る時期になってくるんです
だから決まってる日にちで
ちゃんと雨後として一箇所に止まらなくちゃいけない
そういう場所を探してるんです
三ヶ月はもう一か所にいなくちゃあかんだから
それでこのお母さんがそれをすぐ僕をわかって
ではお坊様はもうこちらに
この村でお泊まりになったらいかがでしょうかと
で もしお坊さんたちが泊まってくれるならば
私もほとんど毎日のようにもう参詣して
部会を受けて で もう戒律を守ることもできるんだと
だいたいこの満月 新月
半月というね 週一回ですね
最強の仏教の人々は修行するんです
現代人は忙しくて一生一回もできんですけどね
大体 1週  1週間 週一回
1日だけでも修行する
だからそれはまあ伝統的な決まりで
彼女はまあ私にもお坊さんたち見ることで
まあ修行もできるんだから
まあお泊まりになればどうでしょうかと
それでお坊さんたちも
ああまあ仏教をよく知っている信者さんでしょうし
このお母さんは ですから
我々にとっては まあ食事にも困ることはないでしょうと
で 托鉢に出たっても 誰一人も出してくれないと
もう飢えに飢えになっちゃいますからね
だからこの お坊さんたちが失うってこと
そんな大した難しいことじゃないんです
托鉢に出たら なんかちょっとこの人何かあげればいいんです
まあ豊かな社会だったらね
まあ出家生活っていうのはそんなに難しくはないんです
で 他人にはね ご飯一皿どころじゃなくて
まあ 1粒あげんぞという生き方になってくると
もう料理作るとは今日は3人だから
微妙に計算して量って3人分だけ作るとかね
これはもうすごい貧困の鈍足ということなんです
で 日本ではね カラス食うの嫌がるでしょ
すごく威張ってるんですね
カラスをいない街を作りましょうと
それぞれマナー守りましょうと
私はこいつらは地獄に住んでいる連中じゃないかなと
マナーって何なのかと
そんなにカラスすんではいけないんですかね
ただ自分で自分の首を絞める生き方をしていて
毎日苦しんで貧困鈍足で生きているでしょうし
だから騙されてるんで
家は立派でしょうし 冷蔵庫やらあるでしょうし
結局食い物ないんだから冷蔵庫で生きていられませんでしょうに
電子レンジあったっても生きていられないんでしょうに
世界の食べ物はもう二五%以上全部日本輸入するでしょうに
なのに食い物がない 何してるんですかね
あれってわからないんです
だからそれも頭の問題ですよ
もう頭狂ってますから
もう管理できん 山ほど食い物あっても食えないんだから
これは餓鬼道なんです
だから日本に餓鬼道から生まれ変わったか
これから餓鬼道に行くかどちらかなんです
だからその準備していると
だってご飯食べるものなくてお腹が空いたというのは悔しくないでしょう
いや 食べ物ないなということでね
あって食えないのはえらい悔しいんですよ
これ餓鬼道だと思いますよ
デパートなんか行くと品物あるあるあるわ
買える？あんなのは お金ある？お金あるところが家賃もろくに払えないんだから
でも行かせにいられないでしょ
買い物じゃなくて見学に
だから精神的に本当に苦しんでますよ
だからわからないだけのことで
わかってもわからなくても
病気は病気だから 自覚症状あってもなくても
ものすごい苦しんでます
で まあ仏教の世界 まあやっぱり慈悲の世界だから
まあジャイナ教でもインドで同じでね
みんなで仲良く生活しましょうという世界ですから
あの この見栄張って自然破壊することではなくて
できるだけみんなで豊かで生きているんです
だから食べ物作ったっても
まあ自分食べたらもうもう皿まで舐めて食べるということはないんです
突然一人が来たらご飯ありますよ
それでそれもったいないでしょうかではないんです
食べる人がいなかったら
まあ動物でも食べさせる
だから野生の動物でもみんなもう仲良く
ずいぶん仲良くするんです
で カラスは迷惑だと思うこと自体
私には自分の国から考えると理解できない
もう結構人間と一緒に仲良くしているのに
いつでもそばに来ているし
全然迷惑も何もかけないし
で 大人ではなくて子供なんか外でご飯を食べると
子供がそこら辺見るとちょこっと取ったりするしね
あげなかったらちょこっと取ったりするし
子供は子供なりにカラスが来るし
あげたりもするし それすっごくものすごい美しいんですよ
そういう状態っていうのは
決して子供に迷惑をかけませんよ
野生の動物であろうとも
大人の不注意で弁当盗るんだったらそのまま全部引っ張りますけど
子供の場合はそうはしません
ちょっと一口取るだけ
そこまで考えてるんだから
そういうカラスは殺そうと
だから渡り鳥が来たっても食べ物はない
すごい世界ですね で 私たちに向かってもうお前らよりはすごい豊かだとまた言ったりもする
まあ現代の角度から尺度から見ればそうかもしれませんだけど
まあ私は仏教の角度からしかものを見ないんだからね
何言ってるのこのバカという感じになるんです
餓鬼道から来て餓鬼道に行くのにと
我々はものがなくてもえらい豊かにいるんですけど
だから幸福か不幸かっていうのは心の問題でしょ
だから渡り鳥来ても食べ物はない
餌をあげなきゃダメでしょう
あの あの 何ていうんですか
百鳥とかね ソ連からシベリアから来るでしょうに
餌あげないと餌がないんです
田舎に行ってもなかなかもう鳥がいないんですね
よくもこういう坂に来てるなと思いますよ
私は野生動物 虫 鳥たちなんかいない
見えないとものすごく気持ち悪いんです
だからね 野辺でもどこかへ行くと
もしこのあれ 田んぼにいる鳥は何て言いますか
この白鷺とかね いると車止まってでももらっても見るんですよ
見ただけで随分気分爽快になるんです
これでこのケチムラじゃこれは何やってるのと追い出すんだから
稲を食っちゃったらたまったもんじゃないんだと
だからそれで豊かできるんですかね
うちのぐらい少々食っちゃってもいいんじゃないか
俺のはいっぱいありますよという状態はないでしょうし
そういうことで やっぱりこのまあ生命っていうのはね
まあ仲良くした方が楽しいとは思いますよ
で 出家の場合も やっぱりそういうオープンな豊かな社会でないとなかなか成り立たない
仏教は真理は世間からなくなっちゃうんです
もう地獄の世界が現れちゃうんです
だから このお坊さん６人もこのおばさんがね
お母さんがね まあこちらへ泊まっていただければ
私にも修行できるんだよと思ったら
なるほど まあ来てるぐらいでも信者さんにはそのおばさんでもみんなに言うでしょうね
そういう修行者たちが来たんだから
で 午前中何か料理作っておいてくださいと
托鉢に来ると 一さじぐらいあげてくださいと
一さじぐらいちょっとあげたってもね
これでもう経済的に倒産しましたっていうことはないでしょうし
でもものすごい徳が積むでしょうし
そういう人々は修行して人類のために働くでしょうし
だから どこら辺にいるホームレスやらね
貧しい人にあげたっても
ご飯あげたらそれ食べてそれから酒飲んで寝るだけでしょう
何が貢献するんですかね
当然貧しいということは当たり前なんですけど
やっぱり自分が寄付したものはもう 1億倍
何倍ももう 1億倍じゃないんで
お釈迦様の数はすごいんですからね
生かすでしょうし 役に立つところにあげれば
まあそういうことで あの
お布施ということはかなり仏教の道徳ではね
強調して言ってますけど
だからお坊さんたちが
ああ まあこの一人 このおばさんいるんだから大丈夫やということで決めるんです
安居に入ることを  [音楽]そのお坊さんたちもまあしっかりもんで
あのまあこのお母さんがね
住むところ 場所をね まあちゃんと用意してあげましたし
そこでまあ自分たちでもちゃんとこのまあほとんどまあ村から離れてね
森とかそういうところであの
作りますから まああちこち物を拾ってきてね
で お坊さんたちはこう決めるんです
我々は怠ってはいけませんと
なぜかというと あの地獄は
あの大きな大地獄は八あるんです
仏教の世界では で 八に回す周りの地獄は百八ですね
で 三十二があって 三十二周りに八十八個ずつあります
で 計算できんだからまあ数えてみてください
大地獄は八で 周りは三十二で八掛ける三十二でしょ
そこをまた掛ける百八なんです
ではないか 足さないとかんですね
三十二に百八ついてますからね
三十二掛ける八で その答えに八を足すんです
それ地獄の数なんです
だからこの 我々一般的に地獄に落ちたとか
天国に行ったとか そういうもう単純なあの一個二個あるわけじゃないんです
それぞれ業によって違うし
で 苦しみ方もそれぞれ違うんです
また餓鬼道という地獄もありますから
これがもう数えられないんですね
それはなんか個人の世界みたいですね
個人の業によって苦しみの世界が現れちゃうんですね
だから餓鬼道はどれぐらいっていうことはなかなか言えない
ただ一つで餓鬼道と言うんですね
餓鬼道の中で あの苦しみはいろいろあるんだったような
で 餓鬼道っていうのはどういうことか
苦しみ 一般的な苦しみっていうのは
あるのに手に届かない苦しみなんですね
それは餓鬼道は一般的な
だから何が手に届かないかということによって個人差があるんです
で 人間の周りにもいるんです
餓鬼は そちらには人間の世界は見える
見えるんだけど もう何も触ったりする何もできん
だからあまりにも人間の世界が欲しくて
ものすごい執着しているんだから
霊になって周りにいるんです
でも食べ物は見えるんですけど
食えない 自分の妻やら息子やら
もうもう可愛くて見えるんですけど
触ったりすることも喋ったりすることもできん
自分が全くない態度で生きているんです
もうないんだ 死んじゃったんだから
自分が大事にした品物やら
もう売ったりとかね 粗大ゴミ処理したりとかする
これものすごいキツいんです
だから泣いたり喚いたりする
でも向こうには聞こえない
自分には何の管理もできん
そこでみんなこのおひあいとか
もうなんか仏壇みたいなものを作って
そこらでもうラーメンやらご飯やら
このちょっとちょびっと入れておくでしょ
食えないんです それでものすごく悔しくなるんです
まあちょっと自分のことを忘れてないなというぐらいの安らぎなんです
だからそれさらに餓鬼道にいる人々は苦しむんです
でお経をあげたっても
そのお坊さんがもう今商売だからね
で 家族もまあもう命日だから
お坊さんにこれぐらいお布施なんとかって
そういう全く商売的に考えるでしょ
だからとくにならん それでさらに悔しくなるんです
そうやって精神的なすごい苦しみを餓鬼道は受けるんですよ
まあそれ人間の周りにいる人だけ周りにいない
またものすごくいるんだから
それぞれの苦しみが違う
地獄はそうではなくて
苦しみが一応もうプログラミングしているんです
そちらに落ちたらそのプログラムを受けなくちゃいけない
その差なんです だからそれで地獄ももう結構どれぐらいありますか？計算した
32掛ける8ですか  108
108 すごい 8を足す
それに8を足す  32掛ける8が256ですよね
そこ32掛ける108
108  32掛ける108 3456
に8を足すんですか 3464
3464 それぐらい地獄あるんです
3464ぐらい それも足らんと思いますけど
生命の数と考えると で
なんでそういうことを言ったのかと
このこちらな注釈書にっていうのは
このスリランカで戦争されたもんですから
時々スリランカ人の考え方やらね
ちらちらと入っているし
だからパーリ語も遠い昔我々使ってたシンハラ語の単語の順番とかね
あるんだから ちょっとわかりにくいところあるんです
自分もスリランカ人だからといって
この昔の言語わからないんです
随分使い方違うんです
パーリ経典は純粋パーリ語で読めばパーッと一括でわかりますけど
注釈書読む場合は あれ
これ何言ってるのかというね
それでなんとかこのシンハラ語になんとか入れ替えてみると
あ なるほどとわかってくるんです
というところもあります
だから これは我々一般的にしゃべる言葉で書いてますけど
あの このお坊さん長老がね
この八大地獄は自分の実家みたいなものだよと
だから怠ってはあかんと
だから怠る者にとっては実家ですよ
八大地獄は という意味で言ってるんです
実家だから帰るのは当然でしょう
だから我々の実家といえばね
八大地獄ですよと だから怠ってはいけませんと
私たちは瞑想指導を誰から受けたと思っているんですかと
この前世先祖のお釈迦様だよと
ブッダは騙せると思っているんですか？だから修行したんだぞとか言ってね
もう森の中に 3ヶ月もいたって
何もやってないと これは明確にバレるんだと
だから  1分も怠ることなく
しっかりと釈迦様に教えられたように修行しなくちゃいけない
だから一人一人別々に住みましょうと
口を利かんことにしましょう
時間ないんだと おはようございますとかなんとか言うと
その三十秒っていうのはもったいない
サティの実践できんでしょ
とんでもない お釈迦様に怒られるんだ
だから口向けがない 一人一人で別々なところでじーっと 24時間体制で修行する
しかし お勤めとかね したり
大長老に会って挨拶するとか
その時間だけみんな集まりましょうと
それから托鉢に出る前
みんな一箇所で集めて
みんなでいっぺんに托鉢に出ましょう
で 帰ってからまたみんなバラバラバラと別々にいきますということで
それで誰かが一緒にいるのは托鉢する時だけ
村に入る時はみんな 六十人も並んで一緒に行く
一旦森に入った途端 それぞれみんな別れて自分たちのところに行く
そういうことにしようと
もし誰かが病気になったりとかね
問題を受けたりすると
大体みんなにお知らせする鐘がありますから
鐘でも何でも音を立てるものでいいんですから
それ鳴らしちゃえばみんな来ますよと
来て病気だったらちゃんと看病しますよと
その時はちゃんと看病することを
すごい厳しい仏教はね
誰かが病気になったらすぐ行って
誰でもいいんだからすぐ看病しなくちゃいけないんです
それである日 このお母さんが
毎日托鉢するんだから
来るんだからね で 一回自分でもうみんなに料理作って
瞑想するところに持っていこうと
行って いっぱい食べ物を作って
お手伝い人やらみんな連れて行って
ご飯を運んで道場に行ったんです
行ってみたら一人もいない
どうしようかと 集まるところはその場所だけ信者さんも知ってますから
それはお母さんが用意してあげたところで
一人もいない どうしよう
どうしようかと それで周りの他の人々にも聞いたら
まあ大丈夫ですよと みんなもう時間になるまで修行中ですから
誰にも会えないんだと
で でも今日は托鉢に出なくてもよろしいしですから
こちらに来てほしいんですけど
どうやって呼べばいいんでしょうか
そうか だったらそちら何か音を立てるものあるんですから
それ鳴らしちゃえば来るんじゃないかなと
そしたらこのお母さんがそちらで鐘がありまして
鐘を鳴らしたんですね
鳴らしたところでお坊さんたちはこの音を聞いて
瞑想をやめて あっちからこちらから一人一人来るんです
お母さんからなんで一人一人で来るんですかと
二人で来ない あっちこっちから一人
もしかするとこの男たちが何か喧嘩したんじゃないかなと
互いに それでお母さんだからね
結構もう何でも聞くでしょうしね
お母さんたちだからね
お坊さんたちが何でもそんな調子で喧嘩でもしたんですかと
そしたら違いますよと
それは我々はこういう風に修行することに決めているんだと
ということで どういう風に修行するんでしょうかと聞いたんですね
私たちは一緒に集めたらこの不浄観の瞑想するんだと
三十二の不浄観 一人一人になってくるとヴィパッサナー瞑想するんだと
それでみんなでやる瞑想だと
このお母さんがどうでしょうか
その瞑想っていうのはこのあんた方だけにできることでしょうかと
我々在家の信者さんにもできますか？と
言ったら  三十二の不浄観とかそれはできますよと
と調べたらそこはOK
すごい気持ちよく住めるところ
次に付き合いの仲良くしている人々の問題
一緒にいる人々 合わないともうとんでもないことになるんです
気が合わないと瞑想できないんです
じゃあ この人々にはこの環境でこの付き合っている人々の問題が何かあるのかと
それ全くない みんなすごい気が合うグループなんです
そういうのはうまくいってる
何だろうと  3番目は食べ物なんです
食べ物に何か問題あるのかと
ずっとやっぱり食べ物には問題があると
托鉢するんだから いつでも自分に体に合うものをもらうということじゃないでしょうし
もらったものを食べなくちゃいけないでしょうに
これは栄養には問題あるんだということで
それで 彼女は自分の多神数で
その一人一人のお坊さんには体に適している食べ物は何なのかと自分で考えて用意して作るんです
あのお坊さんはおかゆを食べた方がいいと
あの人は野菜を食べた方がいいとかね
あの人はもうちょっと硬い
こういうものを食べた方がいいとか
自分ではもう知ってるんです
それは用意してそれぞれあげるんです
そういうことで お坊さんたちが何の事なく軽々と修行を進んで悟り開くんですよ
それでお坊さんたちがね
このお母さんのおかげで悟り開きましたということで
それでお釈迦様にまた報告しなくちゃいけないし
でお母さんに お母さんもお母さんのおかげで修行はもう完成しましたと
それでお釈迦様に行って報告します
したいんですけど いかがでしょうかと
そしたらどうぞどうぞ行ってくださいと
私のことも忘れないでくださいと
でお坊さんたちがずっと長旅を出て
またお釈迦様に会って
[no sound]お坊さんたちが何のことはなく軽々く修行を進んで悟り開くんですよ
それでお坊さんたちがね
このお母さんのおかげで悟り開きましたということで
それでお釈迦様にまた報告しなくちゃいけないし
でお母さんに お母さんもお母さんのおかげで修行はもう完成しましたと
それでお釈迦様に行って報告します
したいんですけど いかがでしょうかと
そしたらどうぞどうぞ行ってくださいと
私のことも忘れないでくださいと
でお坊さんたちがずっと長旅に出て
またお釈迦様に会って
まあ自分が悟り開いたんですけど
どちらかというとあのお母さんのおかげですと
あのお母さんがあれほど頑張ってくれなかったら
もう心は統一できなかったと
ということで この自分たちにはもう想像できないほど
もう褒めきれないほど自分たちの面倒を見てくれましたと
いうことで ものすごく褒めたんです
お母さんのこと でお釈迦様もすごくそこは認める
そのお母さんは素晴らしい人だと
それはあるお坊さんが聞いているんです
もう瞑想するためには
あの場所ほど最高なところないんだと
こういうお母さんがいて
もう何でも面倒見てくれるんだと
だから微妙にでも心に心残りなく修行できるんだと
それで来たお坊さんが
だったら私もそちらに行って瞑想した方が楽ちんじゃないかなと
いうことで 自分もそちらに行くんです
お坊さんがそのお寺に行く
で この人はこう考えるんだ
お寺に入って このおばあさんがもう人の心は知ってると言ってますけどね
それで私は随分長旅をして
お寺に入ったのは入ったんですけど
ものすごく疲れている
だから大掃除しなくちゃあかんでしょうね
もう庭の掃除やら建物の掃除やら大変な仕事で
私にできるわけじゃない
もう疲れているし だからあのお母さんがね
まあ誰か手伝いしてくれる人でも送ってくれればいいのにとか思ったら
あのお母さんもあの坊さんがそんなこと考えてるんだっていうことで
家にいるお手伝いしてくれる人々
何人かおったんで 行ってあんた
君たちお寺掃除してこいと
そこでまた 何か飲み物なんか欲しくなっちゃって
それは黒砂糖を入れてる何か飲み物あるみたいんです
で それやればって それをもらったんですね
思って で いろいろあれ欲しいこれ欲しいと思う
思ったらすぐそのお母さんがもう送ってあげるんです
で 最後にそういうことを考えるんですね
で また会ったことはないんです
このお母さんに 自分がお母さんに何も言わないで
すーっとお寺に入っただけ
寺に入って この村に住んでるあのお母さんがお坊さんの心読めるんだったら
ということで態度でかいんですね
で 送ってくる人が来て
寺をきれいにしてくれたし
次の日は自分の好きな食べ物もらったり
次の日自分好きな食べ物もらったし
思った通りに お母さんがいろいろごちそう持ってきて寺に来るならばありがたいなと思ったんです
と思ったら 次の朝 お母さんがもう全部食べ物作って持って行ったんです
会いに あのお坊さんが何か私に会いたがっているんだということで
そこでお坊さんが名前マーティカマータという名前なんですけど
マーティカマータっていうのはそなたでしょうかと
はい そうなんですけど
でお釈迦様のところでね
お母さんが人の心読めるという話があったんですけど
それ本当ですか？と そしたらお母さんが
なんであんた私に聞くんですかね
大体仏教でははいそうですと言わないんです
自分の能力は表現しないんです
君 なんで私にそんなこと聞くの？と言って怒ったんです
キンマンブッチシタートマヤーチチンチトチッタンサッバンアカセッテエナタン
なんで聞くんですかね
だって私はいろんなことをあれやこれやとか勝手に思ったんですけど
全部その通りになったんだからということで
この若いお坊さんももう言うんです
そしたらお母さんがね
このブッダの弟子たちの中で
人の心読めるお坊さんたちのサラニいるんだよと
いくらでもいるでしょうと
そんなお坊さんたちが
他心通 それでこの人は
私は他のお坊さんに他心通能力あるかとか聞いてるんじゃなくて
そのお母さんにあるのかと聞いてるんだよと
それでお母さんがそう言われると
でも言わなかったんですね
でお母さんがね まあそれぐらいお世話っていうのは大体別に他心通がなくてもできるぐらいのことで
何考えてるんですかということで
まあ何も言わないで帰るんですよ
そこら辺でこの仏教の論理性とその客観性というのは見事に守っているんです
だから若いお坊さんが私はおかゆ食べたかったんで
ちゃんとおかゆ来たんじゃないですかとかね
私は黒砂糖と飲み物 水
飲み物が欲しかったんですけど
ちゃんときたんじゃないかと
おばあさんが お母さんが
あのね まあこれぐらいのごく普通に誰もがやることですからね
そんな他心通なくても
ということを言ったんです
そこであの若いお坊さんがすごく怖くなっちゃったんです
もうもう話したってもうもう自分が負けただけで
なかなかもうもう言ってくれないし
これが大変なことになったと
私はまだまだ凡夫で 全く普通の人間だと
心っていうのは信頼できないんだと
汚いことも考えるは いいことも考えるは
もうもう貪瞋痴いっぱいだから
自分の心は何考えるかとわからないんだと
悟ってないでしょうし
お坊さんにふさわしいことを考える時もあるし
お坊さんは決して考えていけないことでも考えてしまうということもあるでしょうし
こちらではいることはできんと
だってあのおばあさんが全部知ってるんだから
だからもし私が万が一悪いことでも考えちゃうと
この現行犯で捕まるような感じで
あのお母さんには捕まりますよと
逃げた方がいいよと言って逃げるんです
そこで それでもやっぱりお母さん
私は一応もうこれから帰りますよと
そしたらどこに帰るんでしょうかと
あんたはそちらに住んで修行してくださいと
どこに行くの？お釈迦様のところにまた戻りますと
お釈迦様に戻ったって同じことなんですけど
それでとにかくもう逃げたんです
怖くなっちゃって おっかないと
もう瞑想できるとこじゃないっていうことで
で まあ逃げてお釈迦様のところに行って
なんで君が修行に行ってすぐ帰ったんでしょうかと言ったら
おばあさんがお坊さんが全部お釈迦様には報告します
実はこういうことで あのお母さんっているところでは修行できないんだと
私はもうまだ凡夫でだらしないし
何考えるか自分でもわからないんですから
お釈迦様がそれダメですと
君はそちらに帰りなさいと
そのところに帰って修行できません
できません そちらももう怖いと
お釈迦様にも断る またお釈迦様は君はそちらに行って修行しなさい
いくらなんでもさ そちらにはもう行きたくないと
ものすごく怯えているんです
あちらには行きたくないんだと
でお釈迦様もすごく親切に
だったらあんたね もうたった一つだけ守ってみなさいよと
これあれこれと考えることはまずやめなさい
あのお母さんに他心数あるのか
あるいはご飯食べたい
おかゆ食べたいとかね
お前も妄想しすぎやと
だからもう一切考え方やめたらどうですかと
他心数あったっても 何も考えてないんだったらね
ただそれだけのことでしょうと
だからしっかりと他のことは全部無視して心だけ守ってやるそうと
守ってくださいと で 帰れと
元のところにまた帰させるんです
それでお坊さん まあなるほど
そういう方法もあるのと
あ そういう方法あるんだと
何も考えないでいた方がいいと
そうしちゃうと もう読めるところじゃないんだからということで
もうそれでかえって阿羅漢になるんです
元々何も考えてはあかんですから
そこはこのだらしないお坊さんに
そういうことでうまくいきました
まあそういうことで この心だけ守りなさいと
他はどうでもいいんだよと
考え方だけ全部やめなさいと
他は気にする必要ないんだよという
私はしょっちゅう言ってるアドバイスなんです
で 言われて悟りましたが
お釈迦様はそれでも心っていうのはなかなか質が悪くて
調教しがたいものであるというね
偈をその出来事について語られたんです
で そこら辺で私は疲れましたので
話を終了したいんです
とにかく人間のね まあすべて心が作ってるんです
それだけよく覚えてください
建物も心が作るし 農業も心がやってるし
商売も心がやってるし
勉強も心がやってるし
だから自分の性格悪いかというと
それは心はそういうこと